hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo lo
saluda juliet riaño
[Música]
pasados seis meses desde el inicio de la
guerra de rusia contra ucrania el éxodo
continúa los desplazamientos dentro y
fuera de sus fronteras siguen aunque el
flujo disminuyó y un buen número de
personas retorno los países de europa
son los principales receptores de los
refugiados y solicitantes de asilo que
piden protección a medio año después el
fin del conflicto no parece estar cerca
revisemos a continuación algunos de los
datos que deja una de las crisis
humanitarias de más rápido desarrollo en
el continente
cruces masivos lejos de la guerra el 24
de febrero marcó un antes y un después
para millones de personas que tuvieron
que dejar ucrania por la invasión rusa
seis meses más tarde el éxodo interno
continúa y por los pasos fronterizos se
siguen reportando salidas la agencia de
la onu para los refugiados estima que
más de 11 millones huyeron es decir más
del 27 por ciento de la población del
país al menos 5 millones de refugiados
ingresaron a polonia el principal
receptor otros fueron a rusia hungría
rumanía eslovaquia moldavia y belarús un
total de 66 millones buscan refugio en
los países de europa pero en ese flujo
también se reportaron retornos acnur
estima que más de 38 millones regresaron
a ucrania considerada como una de las
crisis humanitarias y de desplazamiento
de más rápido crecimiento de la historia
como consecuencia de la guerra en
ucrania opaco otras crisis
dynamics
aunque ésta es sin duda la mayor y más
dinámica crisis de los refugiados no es
la única el gran problema que tenemos en
este momento es que tiende a marginar a
todas las demás crisis en las que la
gente sufre también de la misma manera
porque los combates los conflictos la
guerra la violencia la mala gobernanza
les obliga a huir de sus hogares
but governance for state leader juegos
por lo que el llamado a los países es
atender todos los desplazamientos
forzosos en el mundo de la misma forma
complex city of the flow softbol
arriving y new rock entiendo la
complejidad de los flujos de personas
que llegan a europa entiendo también la
política que rodea todas esas
situaciones sería muy ingenuo si no
entendiera todo eso sin embargo mi
postura es sencilla si esto es posible
para un número tan grande de personas
que ha demostrado ser tan eficaz por qué
no utilizar algunos de esos enfoques
también para otras personas que vienen a
llamar a las puertas de europa y usa
modis approach es un show por ader
people that are coming to now cut europe
store en el mundo más de 89 millones de
personas salieron de sus hogares por la
fuerza en 2021 y la guerra en ucrania
aceleró esa cifra en 2022 por lo que se
estima que ya son más de 100 millones
los desplazados forzosos en el globo
el desplazamiento forzoso desde ucrania
deja gran parte de la carga de la
acogida a los países cercanos a polonia
huyó la mayoría y para otros sirvió como
nación de tránsito veamos a continuación
que ha pasado con algunos de los
refugiados que deja el conflicto con
rusia
este antiguo pabellón comercial sirve
ahora de refugio y se convirtió en una
solución temporal para algunos de los
que huyeron de ucrania por la guerra y
muchas personas que no tenían lugar ni
idea de a dónde ir y están esperando a
ver cómo evoluciona la situación así que
han estado aquí durante muchas semanas y
la vida continúa para ellos por lo que
los voluntarios aquí intentan mantener
vivas algunas actividades cotidianas
para muchos polonia es el lugar donde
planean establecerse está cerca de su
natal ucrania pero lejos de los
bombardeos olas se quedará por ahora
consiguió un trabajo completamente
diferente al que tenía en su país trata
de acomodarse y aprender
ya cuando comenzó la guerra vine a
polonia y tenía que encontrar un trabajo
el único trabajo que me ofrecieron fue
un puesto de trabajador de almacén con
la posibilidad de capacitar me como
operador de montacargas estoy interesada
en desarrollar me en la adquisición de
estos conocimientos y en tener nuevas
experiencias
en otro lugar de europa un aeropuerto en
desuso en berlín acoge a varios
refugiados ucranianos en contenedores
adecuados como viviendas la ciudad está
llegando a su punto máximo de capacidad
para la acogida por ahora unas 400
personas se quedan aquí
tenemos alrededor de 25.000 personas
alojadas actualmente en nuestros centros
de recepción en todo berlín tanto
ucranianos como solicitantes de asilo de
todo el mundo y sólo nos quedan unos
pocos cientos de lugares como ven aquí
pronto llegaremos a la medida máxima de
nuestra capacidad de alojamiento por eso
es tan urgente poner remedio a este
problema con todos los medios a nuestro
alcance jets mets
a kilómetros de allí en este campus
universitario en taiwán jóvenes
ucranianos estudian gracias a algunas
becas pero las recientes tensiones con
china los llevan a recordar lo que
vivieron hace algunos meses
cuando llegue a taiwán al dormitorio
escuchaba el sonido de los aviones
militares todas las mañanas estaba
asustada porque mentalmente estaba
afectada por la guerra en ucrania
estos jóvenes dejaron atrás a sus
familias y esperan el fin de la guerra
para volver a su país en estos seis
meses de guerra los refugiados
ucranianos llegaron incluso a cruzar el
océano atlántico para alejarse de la
guerra algunos se trasladaron hasta la
frontera norte de méxico en busca de
asilo en eeuu hasta qué inmigrantes de
france24 los invitamos a comentar en
nuestras redes sociales con el hashtag
migrantes f24 sigan con más información
en france 24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]